sie ist man nein ich würde sagen
höchstens 17
besonders willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute ist die der gratiseintritt
auf youtube und der geht darum dass man
das alter sei also so als hätte ich darf
mir das machen heute auch mal oder das
habe ich natürlich wieder meinen
standard theme eines kroaten staat jana
und matsch und ihr habt mir bilder von
euch zugeschickt werden jetzt heute
durchgehend ich und max zusammen und
werden versuchen werden und besser euer
alter erlebt und wir legen jetzt ist es
wieder nicht bedient ich weiß nicht wie
alt ist der ich glaube jetzt ziemlich
jung ich ja ich sag 16
ich würde sagen 17 17 oder 18 ist er 18
schon jetzt erst gesagt als erstes 16 16
ich würde auch schon sagen auf jeden
fall deutlich älter als 14 vielleicht so
scheer
er sagt ich 14 bin ja aber älter als 14
jahre 2014 15 jäger max falls ihr das
nichts bitte sag mir wie du dann
eigentlich danke glaub ich würde sagen
sie's einfach aus der hüfte okay ich
sage einfach 17
ich war 16 als ich glaube die sind noch
nicht sie doch doch ich hab dich 17 ich
habe ich 17 oder älter auf jeden fall
okay okay dafür aber ich würde sagen
über 18 aber du bist dran
also ich würde sagen wir mal nächste
seite
[Musik]
ich glaube es könnte aber auch schon
fast eine zweite for science fiction 20
21 sein ich würde sagen max 19 sagt ich
sag 20 nächste so ich fange an
ok ich glaube 15 jahren 16
ich weiß was jetzt machen weil ich so
mache ich hab mal rauskommt beziehen
damit den score ok und der gewinner
kriegt meine gesamten youtube einnahmen
in diesem jahr wir haben cash der bald
und zwar zehn euro
junge du bist finden das leder ist cdu
ich habe keine ausbildung in amazon bzw
wer fängt an mit alter weiterhin zuerst
geschossen aber jetzt vision punkt er
ist jetzt punktet irische papiere
du musst einfach nein nein auf keinen
fall
ich würde sagen die ist höchstens 17 12
gesicht ich weiß nicht was 12 sommer
richtig kasse hatte es wird welche
niemals gedacht wird
ein zu null für dich ich würde sagen 16
es ist 15 du hast nur glück jungen kann
ja gar nichts von ihr kennt ja klar muss
seine augen aufmachen wenn du musst man
gesehen und das ist geht man okay
okay ich habe in seinem kopf ist don
quixote 14 14
ich sage auch ich selbst 13 ok ich würde
sagen die gute hier ist auf jeden fall
13 jahre alt 14 40 für mich sind damals
noch ein punkt wo ich zeig dir ich zeig
dir
guck mal damit komme ich dich dabei
kauft der familie
das fange ich an 14 ich muss mit meiner
übermenschlichen gase alter zu erkennen
einfach 15 beide
aber die sind schon krass ist an diesem
fakt bleibt dass autodesk bedeute ich
würde sagen die beiden sind zehn nicht
am 11
naja ich bin so gut es gibt noch einen
weiteren mega punkte jetzt jetzt 5
bekommt er hätte mir punkt ich weiß
nicht außerirdische hallo
ja okay dann seid ihr bereit die den
letzten punkt macht papier kirsch sein
papier
ich sage die gute 16 jahre alt fach
genau dass ihr die auch gesagt er hat ja
etwas krasses raus du deswegen ist der
alte ist verschiebt er doch heftiger als
gedacht ich würde sagen okay ich sage 50
karriere nach unten
er ist
[Musik]
du musst so basiert die männer t shirt
jetzt nein ich kaufe ich habe keinen
bezug auf die angesagt das unternehmen
kauft muss überhaupt und ich probier mal
die aktien können euro verfügte scheiße
alle leute vielleicht hast du schon mal
einige krasse nummern auf jeden fall
dabei macht es nicht eine beschreibung
von legend power heute irgendwie so
leicht aber ich ja also wir wollen gern
aber guten leute hier bekommt ihr
persönliches vorgeschlagen die ihr könnt
hier geht's zur neuesten folge von was
das geht sehr lohnenswert wien habe es
dann auch sein was gut und ok
google-sprecher sign live